simplify the cube root of 125 x to the
sixth y to the third power so taking the
cube root of something is the same thing
as raising that something to the one
third power so this is equal to
x to the sixth y to the third power
raised to the one third power and if we
take a product of a bunch of stuff and
raise that to the one third power that's
the same thing as individually raising
each of the things to the one third
power and then taking the product
so this is going to be equal to
125 to the one third power
times
times x to the sixth
to the one third power
times y to the third to the one third
power
and then we can think about how we can
simplify each of these 1 25th what's 125
to the one-third well let's just factor
it and see if we can have at least three
prime factors of something and maybe and
maybe more than one prime factor that
shows up three times so 20 125 is 5
times 25
25 is 5 times 5.
so 125 really is 5 times 5 times 5. so
if you multiply 5 times itself three
times you get 125 or 20 125 to the one
third power is going to be is going to
be five so this is going to simplify to
five
times
and then x to the sixth to the one third
power we saw this in a previous example
if you raise a base to an exponent and
then raise that whole thing to another
exponent you can take the product of the
two exponents so 6 times 1 3 is 6 3 or
2. so this part right over here
simplifies to
x to the 6 divided by 3 power or x
squared
x squared and then finally over here
same principle raising y to the third
power and then that to the 1 3 power so
that's going to be y to the 3 times 1 3
power or y to the first power and then
times y
and we are done and if you don't want to
write this little multiplication here
you can just write this as 5
x squared 5 x squared
5 x squared y and we have simplified